an army of Time Travelers has arrived
from the future to ask for help the
world is going to end in the hands of
the deadly aliens and the only way to
stop it is to travel to the Future and
fight in tomorrow's War Dan Forester is
a high school science teacher but his
biggest dream is to work in the military
science labs he applies for the job and
reaches the final testing Dan is really
excited and informs her wife Emmy and
her sweet little daughter my they are
having a Christmas party at home and my
wants Dan to spare some time time to
watch the football match with her but he
suddenly gets a call from the employer
and excuses himself the employer tells
Dan that he is a great candidate but
lacks experience in this field therefore
they have selected someone else for this
post poor Dan returns home and watches
the football match to distract himself
It's the final match and all fans have
glued their eyes on the ground but
suddenly something unexpected happens a
weird portal opens in the middle of the
ground and a bunch of soldiers step out
of it they claim to be part of the
future 30 years ahead in their time the
world is almost destroyed by an alien
attack and just a few of them are left
they need more enforcement to stop
humans from getting extinct that's why
they have traveled back to the past to
take more soldiers with them this
incident shocks the whole world just in
a few months the lives of all the humans
completely changed jump facilities are
built around the globe to send the
world's military into the future and
help fight the aliens called White
spikes in the first batch 1,000 soldiers
are sent to into the future for 7 days
there were high hopes from them but
unfortunately only a handful of troops
survived due to the lack of enough
qualified Soldiers the governments
decide to send selected civilians a
second batch of 1,000 civilians are sent
to the future but it's still not enough
now the public is getting doubtful of
these efforts and wonder if they are
even worth it there are protests all
over the world and no more civilians are
willing to take part in this Mission so
the government takes a brutal step and
starts kidnapping people to force them
to go on this Mission this causes an
even worse impact on the public and they
have given up on their lives their loved
ones are thrown into hell and even if
the rest of them survive they have to
face the aliens in the future anyway
Dan's students have the same concerns
but Dan explains that the most valuable
people in the current circumstances are
the scientists if they focus on science
they can invent something to deal with
the aliens little does Dan know that he
is the next candidate for this Mission
he gets called in by the jump facility
that is supervised by the soldiers that
arrived from the future they use a
special device to check when Dan will
die any civilian who is going to die in
the next few years must serve in this
Mission Dan is supposed to die just
after the next 7 years so he gets chosen
to jump to the Future War a weird device
is pierced onto his arm which will allow
the facility to locate his activities so
he can't run away if he tries to remove
the device he will be thrown in jail and
his wife will need to serve in his place
Dan is given one day to meet his family
and friends friends Emily panics on
hearing this news and suggests that they
should run away with their daughter
there's only one man who can help them
and it's Dan's father Dan hasn't met him
for years because he abandoned the
family when Dan was just a little kid
he's an expert in engineering but
there's no visible source of his income
and he lives in a shady place that's why
Dan never visits him his dad assures
that the tracking device can be removed
but Dan starts talking about the past
and how his mother struggled alone
hearing this his dad says that there's a
lot Dan doesn't know he left the family
to protect them from himself Dan doesn't
understand and believes that his dad is
just making excuses and doesn't deserve
another chance this enrages him so much
that he refuses to get the help and
returns home he tells Emily that they
have no other option than hoping that
Dan survives the 7even days Mission he
also says goodbye to Mory and Promises
to return back soon the next day he
reports to the facility for training
where a sergeant briefs the mission all
those who stay alive after 7 days will
be teleported back to the present their
training doesn't include any exercise
like in the military they are only
taught to use weapons the civilians get
divided into two groups Dan gets in the
r force and befriends a guy named
Charlie the group also includes a tough
guy named Dorian who is voluntarily
going on this mission for the third time
he is known for killing several white
spikes and he also wears one Spike as a
necklace Dan prefers staying beside
Charlie and hearing his theories Charlie
concluded that they can't jump to the
time where they are already present all
the members of the current round are
those who are already dead in the year
they are jumping to and the people who
came from the future are those who
haven't been born in the current year
Dan likes this Theory and becomes a good
friend with Charlie moreover the time
machine called jump links can only
teleport them back and forth in the year
30 times apart the sergeant explains
that the white spikes crawl back to
their nest after every 6 days so that's
the time they send the troops to carry
out the missions Dan and other soldiers
go to sleep in peace because they assume
that they still have 7 days till the
mission but they are called out in the
middle of the night the labs in the
future are attacked and all the research
done on white spikes is at risk
therefore the troops must be deported
right now they all gathered in a hall
where the portal is opened to take them
to the Future unfortunately due to an
error instead of landing on the beach
the troops fall in the middle of the
city and most of them die by getting
injured a Future soldier named Romeo
contacts Dan and asks him to lead the
mission as he used to work in the
military before their mission is to
rescue the research team from the city
lab Dan tells Two Soldiers to guard the
building while the rest of them enter
the lab unfortunately all the
researchers have been killed but the
bodies are still there so the aliens can
return anytime Romeo tells Dan to
collect several research materials like
flash drives and lab samples he puts
them in a box and proceeds towards the
exit suddenly they hear someone coming
from upstairs it's the white spikes now
the the solders understand why they
weren't shown the pictures of the aliens
they are creepiest creatures one has
ever seen they are huge in size with
several tentacles and hundreds of sharp
teeth the soldiers run downstairs while
continuously shooting at the aliens
Dorian instructs them to aim for the
belly the soldiers try their best but
the aliens are too many in number and
kill several soldiers Romeo tells them
to run as fast as they can she has sent
helicopters and vehicles to rescue them
Dan and other soldiers reach the smoke
signal where the vehicles are waiting
for them but before they can ride them
the white spikes destroy the vehicles
and kill the drivers the remaining
troops run for their lives two of the
brave Soldiers sacrifice themselves to
stop the aliens under the bridge a
missile is thrown on the bridge to kill
the aliens while the survivors are taken
to the military Camp Dorian advises Dan
to act better next time instead of
bothering about saving his mates he
should focus on the mission whatever
happens here doesn't matter they should
worry about changing the past that
brought This calamity Dan doesn't agree
for for him all are humans no matter
which time period they belong to hearing
this Dorian shares his own purpose of
joining the mission again and again he
is suffering from cancer and might die
in a few months he wants to give his
short life a purpose and die in a
memorable way their conversation is
interrupted by a soldier who takes Dan
to meet the commander of the future
military base she tells him that they
have met before and Dan instantly
realizes that it's no other than his
beloved daughter muri she has become a
well-known researcher as she dreamed in
childhood however she seems a little
distant from Dan myy says that her
biggest priority right now is to save
the human species she didn't bring his
dad to spend time with him there's a
special purpose for which Dan is being
chosen before telling him that MRI needs
to explain a few other things she shows
Dan a footage of a female white Spike
it's more aggressive and usually stays
in the nest laying eggs while the male
ones protect her with their lives the
aliens only care about the survival of
their species they somehow managed to
enter the Earth without getting caught
by any radar or satellite for the first
time they appeared in Russia and then
took over all the world Mori has
developed a toxin that works on the male
aliens but the female ones are tougher
their next mission is to bring a female
white Spike to the lab alive Dan joins
this Mission too and they reach the
aliens Nest firstly they kill the males
in the nest with the toxins and then
enter inside to catch the female Dan
stays in the helicopter and keeps an eye
on the surroundings he suddenly sees
more and more aliens proceeding towards
them so he rushes to help his daughter
the female is trapped in a cage and
carried away by the helicopter while Dan
and muri ride a jeep to escape the
deadly area after reaching the beach myy
sends a signal to her team and waits for
its arrival she takes this time as a
chance to scold Dan for following her to
the nest Dan explains that he can't
leave her daughter alone but these words
bring tears in Mor's eyes she says that
she always trusted her father more than
anyone but one day he left her parents
separated when she was 12 and when she
was 16 her dad died in a car accident
Mory saw this all with her eyes and
couldn't get over it she thought that
her dad would save their family but she
was wrong Dan can't believe he is going
to do something that he hates his own
dad for doing before he can say another
word the rescue team arrives and takes
them to their main headquarters located
in the middle of the sea the female
alien is locked in the lab and injected
with toxins every every hour to keep her
under control however her body
detoxifies really quick so MRI needs to
figure out how that happens and then she
needs to design an enzyme inhibitor to
neutralize it once that's done all of
the aliens can be killed and they will
win the war for the next few days mirie
runs tests non-stop she tries 10,000
combinations to discover the toxin but
none of them gives 100% result Dan wants
to help and asks what's his purpose here
muie finally reveals the plan once the
toxin is prepared she wants Dan to take
it back to his time and mass-produce it
to stop the aliens before they spread
she doesn't want to trust anyone else
beside her dad Dan is leaving today and
agrees to take the toxin but he wants to
return back to save Mory once the toxin
is perfected Mory hands it over to Dan
suddenly an emergency is alerted the
white Spikes have eventually found their
headquarters and reached there in
thousands of numbers myy and Dan grab
their weapons and fight the enemies
while standing backto back all the
vehicles and helicopters are also
destroyed so there's no hope left m is
injured too and tells Dan to focus on
the mission he will teleport back any
minute he must take the responsibility
of saving the world and don't let this
cursed future ever happen Dan is not
willing to let her daughter go but his
time is up myay falls in the mouth of
the deadly aliens while Dan and other
survivors get back to their time Dan
asks to send him to the future again but
it's not possible anymore as the jump
Link in the future is destroyed after
recovering from his injuries he gets
back home but can't get over what he
experienced he wants to save the future
muri even if it means saving the whole
world he meets up with charlyy and
Dorian they try to figure out where the
alien spaceship is going to land Dan
takes Dorian necklace to examine the
volcanic ash on the alien Spike then he
takes help from his student who is an
expert in such topics he concludes that
such Ash is buried in the glaciers of
Russia Dan shares his theory with the
government but it refuses to fund his
research now only one man can help them
myy gave Dan a second chance and now
he's going to give his dad a chance too
the old man immediately agrees and helps
them travel to the glaciers they find
the alien spaceship crashed in an ice
cave it will take around 20 years for
ice to melt and the white spikes are
reproducing till then if Dan returns to
government right now it will take too
long to carry out this Mission so he
decides to put an end to it himself they
start injecting the eggs with the toxins
but a few aliens hatch out Dorian tells
Dan to get out while he blasts the
spaceship with a time bomb and gets the
heroic death he wanted unfortunately a
female alien has escaped Dan and his
father follow her and fight while
standing back to back his dad volunteers
to sacrifice himself but Dan saves him
and injects the alien with toxin before
throwing her off the cliff finally he
saved the world and her future daughter
Dan goes back home and also brings his
dad to enjoy the remaining years of his
life in peace making mistakes is human
nature but everyone deserves at least a
second chance